well up until now we've only heard
tidbits of what Donald Trump's economic
platform might look like but with
everyday we're starting to get a little
bit more of a sense of what a president
Trump might do if he ever reaches the
Oval Office so here are some of the
proposals he's discussed just in the
past week raising from his stance on
carried interest to companies moving to
Mexico I would say that the head of Ford
sorry I'm not going to approve you're
gonna pay a tax where every car and
every truck at every part that comes
across that southern border you're gonna
pay a 35 percent tax the carried
interest is really a tremendous burden
on the country I would take carried
interest out and I would let people that
are making hundreds of millions of
dollars a year pay some tax because
right now they're paying very little tax
we have companies with thousands and
thousands of jobs that are leaving this
country to go out and get their money
let the money come in tax it at a much
lower rate and let the money come in I
know the greatest negotiators in the
world like Karl ikons one of the best if
I put Karl charge of Japan Karl handle
Japan trade kills it's over just walk
away let them under run off forget it
they even know that they don't have a
chance okay okay so as a matter of
politics yes Trump anomic may be
appealing but come on as a matter of
policy does any of this actually make
coherent sense first of all I want to
say that I loved hearing the words
earlier of the words President Trump
come out of your mouth that was like one
of my best moments so far the second
thing I want to say is I'm gonna crib
from Albert Reinhold hunch jr. who wrote
this great column in Bloomberg View
today going through what we know of
Trump's economic proposals he says you
know the building up the military very
expensive he's not gonna cut
entitlements Trump he's the carried
interest thing doesn't count doesn't
count for very much the tariffs etc he
says Trump is going to be the biggest
budget buster in the world if you were
president but I defer to you on this
because you are the expert on matters of
budget finance economics business well
okay it needs a budget-busting series of
policies but the other thing is from an
economic standpoint there's not actually
a coherent through-line
right so this is actually to the left of
Barack Obama on carried interest
essentially saying I'm gonna tax Wall
Street and hedge funds at a normal
income level but at the same time lower
the corporate interest rate there so for
corporate taxes which is to the right I
mean a lot
the stuff kind of doesn't have a
particular rule line to it and has a
very protectionist spent in terms of
free trade which he says he's for which
doesn't make sense with a 35% import X
well that is that is the point I just
again I'll ask you you know is there
anybody in conventional in the in the
world of business or economics that you
cover who thinks that slapping a 25%
tariff on Chinese goods and Mexican
Goods and other goods anybody who thinks
that makes economic sense in a word no
in a word no no sense under any
circumstance would be calamitous would
be horrible or de trade war would start
we don't wanna start a trade war we
don't wanna start any kind of Wars okay
so that's clear